Introduced a manual Schanzer Emmanuel is
a creator and Co director of bootstrap
when the largest form our k through 12
computer science initiatives in the US.
He spent several years as a
program manager and developer
before becoming a high
school teacher at the Middle
School academic coach.
And it has long been involved in
connecting educators and technology,
building partnerships with
depression organizations,
universities and companies from across
Silicon Valley to bring a rigorous high
quality cs education to all students,
particularly underrepresented groups.
He holds degrees in computer science and
curriculum development and his research
focus involves using
programming to teach Algebra.
Cool. All right, well thank you. Well,
hi everybody. Thank you. Thank you.
I haven't even started. I want to thank
all of you for being here today and uh,
also as I mentioned before,
I really appreciate you taking a moment
away from the Comey testimony to uh,
to join us here. Um, so it's
great to be back at Google,
so thank you for having me.
I especially want to extend a thanks to
Andrew for the invitation for setting
this up and I'm going to spend the next
35 or so minutes talking to you about
computer science education
formulated as an engineering problem.
So as Andrew mentioned, my name is
Emmanuel. I work with a team. Uh,
their names are up here
on the slides for him.
Krishnamurthy Kathy Fisler and I'm a young
Smith and a bootstrapper right now is
one of the largest formal in school
programming courses in the country.
We reach about 20,000
students every single year.
Most of these students are taught by
teachers with little or no computing
experience. Um, 43% of our
students are girls and young women,
46% self identify as African American
or Latino. So if you're, you know,
counting these numbers, these are pretty
good in the CS education business.
A lot of these classes often struggle
to recruit underrepresented groups. Um,
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about how we did what we did,
where we're going, and uh, hopefully pass
on some of those lessons to you guys,
especially since you were engineers.
And I think this is a problem, uh,
that you guys have a unique way of
looking at. I'm not an engineer's broadly.
Also sales geos here as well, I guess Geo
engineers, but other Googlers overall.
So let's start with a question.
Um,
somebody walks into your
office and says, you know, I,
I want to teach computer science. You
guys are the expert. You work at Google.
So what language should I use? So I'm
just curious, take a second. I want to,
I want to hear like a
couple of suggestions. Like
three, three, three folks.
What would you recommend to
someone who's asking you this?
Right.
Excellent. Scratch. What
else? Python. Great.
One more recommended list
he recommends list. Great. Okay.
There's always one. All right,
sounds good. And this in fact
is exactly the way it goes.
So here's an example of an
actual Facebook thread. Um,
someone asks was on post and says,
Hey,
I'm looking for a device
on teaching some coding.
What do people think I should use? And
the responses are all things like scratch.
Indeed was the first one, someone
else's recommending some logo. Uh,
someone else is looking
at, uh, let's see. Uh,
they're talking about maybe c
plus plus maybe Java or python.
So the answers are all immediately here
are some languages, Harrison tools. Um,
letting ask you a slightly
different question.
Someone walks into your office and
says, Hey, I want to make software.
You guys are Googlers, what language
should I use? So what do you tell them?
What type of software?
So you would push back, you'd say,
well, what kind of software do you want?
It's an android APP.
You have to use Java.
It's a iPhone APP.
Yo see objective c or swift or something.
Yeah. So you're saying that maybe
before you answer with the language,
you would ask a little bit more about
what this person is trying to make. Right?
Even though they came to you asking
for a language, you're saying, well,
back up a second,
what do you want to do?
And I think that's sort of telling
that when someone asks an engineer,
what language should I use? The engineer
says back up, what are you trying to do?
But when it comes to education,
if a teacher says,
what should I use were instantly
quick to jump in and say,
you should use c sharp, you should
use scratch. Things like that. Why?
I mean,
as engineers,
the first thing we should be doing is
looking at what are the constraints of the
problem.
So here are some educational constraints
that we should be asking before we
answer that teacher's question.
How old are the students? Right?
Maybe they're 30 maybe they're five. That
might change our answers a little bit.
Have they had prior programming exposure?
Is it their first program in class or do
they have master's degrees in computer
science?
Is it a required class where you're going
to have every kid there or is it self
selected kids? How long is it
right? Is this to run it on all day,
summer camp, eight hours a day,
every day? Or is it like, you know,
half an hour coding club Monday mornings?
Is it even a class?
Maybe it's a drop in coding club
over at the local science museum.
And some kids are there every day.
Some kids shop once and
you never see him again.
Now I think if I had given you guys
more time to think about this question,
you would have come back with some of
these constraints you would have asked
about them,
but there are some other constraints
that you might not have thought of.
So if you're interested in
getting computer science
into an educational context,
you should also ask yourselves,
how many kids are there? Right?
Is it one teacher teaching a giant lecture
hall or is it just a small group of
kids? Um, similarly,
is there Internet access in the
school or an educational setting?
Is the teacher new to programming maybe
the teacher has never coded before?
Can the students type that
isn't a critical question
that might immediately lead
you to say, well, you know, scratches a
great place to start if they can't type.
Are there students with
different ability levels, right?
Are they visually impaired?
Do they have sensory motor impairments?
If you're talking about schools,
the answer is yes.
And you have to ask what
those impairments are,
what the different ability levels are,
because those will change your answer.
Do they have regular
computer access at home?
Because if you're a programming class
and you're relying on kids completing
programming assignments for
homework, this matters. And in fact,
do they even have regular computer
access at school, right? I mean,
if a teacher says, I want to teach
computer science, we often think, oh,
you must have a computer live.
Kids must have computers every day.
Often what it really means is there's
like a laptop cart that comes around on
Friday.
So these are the constraints that we
need to ask about before we even barge in
and say, well, here's how computer science
education should work. And you know, as,
as computer scientists were often
over fixate on the tool, right?
We jumped into the language,
we jump into the software,
which is why I think when you
look at the last 40 years,
the history of cs education
has a history of tools.
Here's the new tool that's going to
change the way programming has taught
forever.
And then 10 years later,
here's the new new tool that's going to
change the way programming has taught
forever. And this endless
cycle never gets us anywhere.
So let's look at this as engineers
and say, let's define the problem.
What are our constraints
and what are our metrics?
We've talked about our constraints.
I'm going to posit that there are
three metrics we should consider.
So first is equity, right? Without equity,
we could get computer science into every
school and then the only kids who show
up for the class or rich white boys,
and I think none of us would be thrilled
with that. So equity is number one.
We also want scale,
right?
We need this to be reachable by
millions and millions of kids.
And you've got things like hour of code
that reach millions upon millions of
kids,
all kinds of kids.
But even code.org even Hadi Partovi
himself would say hour of code is not
rigorous education.
It's merely exposure.
What we want for our
third criteria is rigor.
If we hadn't gotten all three of these,
I would propose that we're
never fully successful,
we're never where we need to be.
So with these goals in mind,
let's look at the solution space cause
there's sort of four strategies that
people tend to use when
it comes to cs education.
So the first is let's
make it a required course.
Every child in America must take computer
science before they graduate. Okay.
Um, there's a riff on this,
which is, no, no, no, no.
There should be a computer science course
in every school, but it's optional.
It's an elective that kids can choose.
Option three, forget all of that.
We're going after school an option
for maybe instead we try to integrate
computing into some existing mainstream
classes. So let's look at these four.
And I just want to say that, you know,
all four of these strategies have merit.
So as I go through this,
you know,
some have strengths and others
have weaknesses and that's fine.
I think there's room in this space
floor for a plurality of approaches.
So let's start with the
required course, right? Let's,
let's talk about that strategy.
Well,
the problem with required courses is
that require this strategy doesn't scale.
If we really wanted to get computer
science to be taught to every child in
America, and we need to
do four things. First,
we would need to have something called
cs teacher certification in every single
state so that a teacher
could become a CS teacher.
And right now less than half of the
states have such a certification.
So that means a policy effort that's
going to take a lot of years and a lot of
dollars to create.
And then once that's done,
we need to recruit and train at least
20,000 full time dedicated cs teachers.
And that's even more years
and even more dollars.
And then let's just assume that none of
those teachers decide to piece out and
go work for a technology company because
now they can make a whole lot more
money. Let's just assume they
all stay in the classroom, right?
We still have to pay their salaries,
which means at least a billion dollars
a year added to the national education
budget in every single year in perpetuity.
That's not going to happen anytime soon.
But suppose somebody with deep
pockets opens up and says,
I'm going to pay for all of
it. It's totally okay. Well,
beyond paying their salary,
there's also the laws of time and space
and there's a finite number of hours in
the school day and rooms
in the school building.
So where are these cs class is going to
fit, right? It's essentially a nonstarter.
So there's a lot of benefits here, but
right off the bat would give up on scale,
right? That's not happening
with the strategy. Even worse,
if it's a required class that
kids need to complete to graduate,
that means you have wildly different
ability levels in that classroom.
And because it's a graduation requirement,
there's a perverse incentive on the part
of the teacher to get rid of the rigor,
right? To make sure that
every single kid can pass it.
Because we don't want kids dropping out
of high school because they didn't pass
their cs class.
So we may lose some of the rigor as well.
Well,
I mean it often does,
and that's why it's shaded, right?
So some teachers will hold the line,
some teachers will say, no, I'm
going rigorous the whole way.
And that's why it's half on there. Right?
I think some teachers will take that.
We'll take the approach
that you would take.
There are other teachers that
are going to say, you know what?
I wasn't even a CS major. The
fact that I don't know, you know,
this computer science class,
I don't want any kid to fail up,
so we're just going to
do something that's Ah,
that's fun and sort of easy to pass.
And that's just, that's merely a risk.
It's not an a definite outcome.
So let's take a look
at strategy number two.
What if computer science was
simply an elective, right?
That solves some of these problems.
Well,
the problem with elective courses
is that they're not equitable.
And I'll tell you why. So every school
has a set of graduation requirements.
So here's a hypothetical grid of courses
that a student might take in different
subject areas years one through four,
and you can clearly see there's
room for computer science there.
What happens if a kid fails a required
course, for example, Algebra one,
well then they have to retake
it their sophomore year.
So we've just moved this pathway down
a notch, but they're also doubling up.
The school will typically assign
them to a second math class,
like a remedial math class to make damn
sure that that kid passes their Algebra
class this time. And of course they're
missing their fourth year of math.
So what happens? They get another year
added somewhere else in a different track,
maybe financial math, applied
math, something like that,
to give them the credits that they need.
And then over on the column you'll
notice that virtually every science has
Algebra as a prerequisite, right?
Without Algebraic functions,
you're not modeling
projectile motion and physics,
you're not balancing chemical equations.
So often there's a delay introduced
a bubble in the pipeline,
and that's if they fell class once.
What if a kid fails to classes, right?
You had this nice grid structure
that allows for all these courses,
but now there's this cascade of errors.
That means that these students don't
have room in the schedule to take the
electives. So for students who
fail these classes, they're,
they're exed out of these options.
And when you look at the students that
typically struggle in the mainstream
classes, often they split along
class lines, poverty, lines, ses.
And because of some structures
that we have in America,
those are also divided among racial lines.
So these elective courses
are great to have,
but it's no surprise that when you look
at the courses that are being offered
right now as electives,
often there's a particular profile
of student who winds up being in the
classroom. So going back to
our scorecard here, you know,
we lose equity off the bat.
And I think that there is often
something of a risk in losing rigor.
And I'll tell you why,
because for a school that's just offering
a single computer science elective,
it's not cost effective for them to
hire like a full blown computer science
teacher. So what are they gonna
do? Who's gonna teach that class?
So maybe a math teacher, maybe
a history teacher, right?
They'll ask another teacher
to take over that class,
which means we lose the ability to ensure
that they have the necessary training
and depth of content to ensure rigor.
So again, rigorous sort of a risk here.
So let's take a look at strategy three.
What if we did?
What if we just bypass the schools all
together and did computer science as an
afterschool program? Well, this is a
strategy that I can tell you a lot about.
So bootstrap began as an afterschool
program and several years back,
early in our growth,
we were actually one of the largest
afterschool programming curricula in the
country.
And in fact we had tons of engineers from
Google who taught the class and after
school programs. And when we looked at the
impact we were having, we shut it down.
That's a battle scar. And I'm going
to tell you my reasons for doing so.
See the problem with afterschool computer
science is that by definition it has
to compete with afterschool
football, basketball, theater,
sculpture, having a job taking
care of your little brother,
which means the only kids who show up
for afterschool cs are the kids with the
means and inclination to do so.
They already see themselves
as interested in coding.
So equity goes out the window very,
very quickly.
Once you scale beyond a certain group,
you lose equity.
But there's something else which
is that after a long day of school,
kids are exhausted justifiably so,
which means it's extremely hard to
teach a rigorous afterschool programming
class. Now this is not to knock
after school coding clubs.
I think they're fantastic.
I think they add a lot of value.
But I think often the critique that
you hear is this after school thing.
It's really great kids,
they're getting engaged,
but I wouldn't say they're learning
rigorous computer science. Um,
so easy to scale, but you risk
losing some other stuff as well.
So what sort of ruled out the
first three strategies as,
as having some benefits but not
necessarily getting us to the whole,
to all three of our metrics for success.
So I want to pause for a second
and give you an indication
the idea that everyone should learn
computer science does not mean everyone
should take computer science classes.
I think this is,
this is a tenuous connection
that we need to sever.
So I want to talk about
the fourth strategy,
which is what does it look
like to integrate computing
into a mainstream course?
And if you were to pick a course,
any course,
I think you'd want to pick
Algebra and I'll tell you why.
So first Algebra is the gateway to
all stem. As I mentioned before,
you fail Algebra one and you just
give up on math right there. Yeah,
you're screwed for the m part of stem,
right?
You're not going to
become a mathematician,
but you're also not going to come
a physicist without functions.
You're not going to become
a chemist or biologist.
Even if you want to go into economics,
financial literacy,
you need to know Algebraic functions.
If you want to model things
like compound interest.
So a kid who flames out of Algebra one
has essentially made a career decision
where they're, they're
exed out from stem. Um,
in fact this impact is so significant
that a 2004 study looked at the
correlation between grades kids get in
high school and their lifetime earnings.
And what they found was that the greatest
child gets an Algebra one is the most
strongly correlated of any subject with
the amount of money that child will make
for the rest of his or her life.
Okay.
And finally,
we live in an era of high stakes testing
and standardized test and Algebra one
is a requirement in every single
school in the United States,
which means that the superintendent
of New York City public schools isn't
staying awake at night having,
you know, shivering saying,
why aren't my kid learning to code?
What they're really worried about is
are my kids going to be able to pass the
Algebra exams? And this is
happening nationwide, right.
Typically when you hear people compare
how we're doing to other countries,
the thing that that scares us the most is
other countries are beating us in math.
And guess which part of the math
test people freak out about the most?
The algebra. It's a word problems. I mean
it's not only is it not necessarily
required everywhere, but typically when,
when you think about Americans
who are scared of math,
it's always the train leaving Chicago
and the train leaving, leaving New York,
right? It's this like nightmare word
problem that we all we all giggle about,
right? Because it's true. We have like
national PTSD when it comes to Algebra.
So this is a class that's in need of help.
So what if we tried to teach computer
science through the Algebra class?
What if we integrated?
So I'll make a strong claim here that
the integrative strategy is scalable,
equitable,
and rigorous.
Here's why it's scalable because
every child takes Algebra, right?
You're immediately reaching
every child in the country.
You're leveraging the huge
network of existing teachers,
courses and professional organizations
that are already out there.
So we can grab that scale and run
with it to teach computer science.
It's also equitable.
You know why?
Because everyone takes Algebra,
which means right off the bat you're
removing the negative stereotypes that are
accidentally reinforced by things like
electives and afterschool clubs where
when other kids would look at who's
taking those courses, they say, oh,
that that student doesn't look like me,
but if you were in the Algebra class,
we get rid of that right off the bat.
We're all in it together and
it's also fairly rigorous, right?
The content in Algebra is well suited
to rigorous instruction and evaluation.
Algebra teachers confront
issues of abstraction and
funnel notation all the time.
There are some great corollaries here
that can we can put to use to teaching
computer science. So you're probably
sitting here saying, oh my God,
Emmanuel is telling me that, that
this is basically a free lunch, right?
We get all of those metrics for free.
It's fantastic. Do you believe me? No,
because there's no such thing as a free
lunch. So here's what we do, right?
We've essentially traded one set of
challenge and constraints for a different
set of challenging constraints.
So rather than trying to like jam
computer science into a resource starved
educational context, now we have a
different constraint problem to solve.
If we want it to fly,
we have to have transfer,
which means the computer science kids
are learning in the math class had damn
well better result in them learning
math better than they did before.
Otherwise the math teacher's going to just
going to revolt. They're going to say,
I don't care how cool this
is or how useful it is.
My job is to teach math and if I'm
giving up time from my math class,
it better result in improved
math outcomes. Right?
So in cognitive science literature,
this is a phenomenon called transfer.
Transfer is pretty simple.
A skill learned in one context can be
used successfully in a different context.
That's our goal and it turns out
that transfer happens all the time,
but almost never in the way you expect.
If you want to actually guide kids to
transfer, it's much harder than you think.
So how do we guide kids from transferring
skills and computing into Algebra?
Well, we know that there are
three new constraints. Number one,
you have to have explicit instruction.
Having a kid perform task a and then
later having them perform task B,
a and B might seem similar to you,
but you have no guarantee that student
is going to make the connection.
And often without having a teacher
in the room to explicitly tie the two
together, it ain't going to
happen. But that's okay. Right?
We're dealing with math teachers so
we can check that one off. Number two,
the tasks that you're using in domain
a and B have to have deep structural
similarities.
How deep am I talking about?
I'll give you an example from a
2009 case study. They looked at a,
a physics teacher who was talking about
gravity and acceleration and had his
students do tons and tons of problems
where a ball was dropped off of a tower or
off of, um, I don't, out of an
airplane, things like that. And they,
they studied how fast the ball was moving
after a given time where it was after
a given time, all sorts of stuff.
And then they gave the kids a quiz.
The quiz had balls being dropped down
holes and the students complained,
you know why
you didn't show us any whole problems.
So trend like the,
the level of structural similarities
needs to be insanely high in order to
really facilitate transfer.
And finally you need to have a
process for performing tasks, right?
You can't just give kids a problem in
domain a and then assume that they will
magically understand how to transfer
that to solving that problem in domain be
right.
A classic formulation of what I just said
is we often think that we're teaching
kids problem solving simply because we
give them problems to solve and that's
not true. So we've got to have an explicit
task. So these are our new criteria.
We've already got one.
Let's talk about how we get number two
deep structural similarities between
computer programming and Algebra.
Well,
there's a problem because most of the
coding that we do in K12 doesn't actually
have functions. And functions are
kind of important for Algebra.
So a lot of teachers will use
that function machines, right?
There's inputs and outputs.
There's a vertical line test,
except often you have functions
that you know, return,
void or functions that you give
them the same input 10 times,
you get 10 different outputs.
This is perfectly common in
many programming languages. Um,
there's no computer output,
right? Here's a block from a,
a language you might be familiar with.
What's the output of that function?
There's nothing computed
that's showing up.
So for a teacher who's trying to make
connections between the functions on a
computer and the functions and Algebra,
this doesn't fly.
Coding also doesn't have
variables for the most part.
Here's a classic example from python x
equals 10 and now x equals x plus two.
When you run this program,
what's the final value of x class?
Fantastic. Actually, no, that's not
right at all. I'm a math teacher.
This is nonsense.
And you can probably guess why.
And there's actually two
problems here. One is, will.
Can you guess what one of the problems is?
Yeah.
We're overloading the equals sign,
right?
We're treating something that has a
clear definition in mathematics to mean
assignment, right? Assignment is not
equality. So that's a syntactic problem,
but there's something
much deeper at work here,
which is the semantic problem because
assignment does not exist in math.
And for those of us who know
that sometimes state can
be a little bit hairy when
you're writing code,
right?
State is a known challenging thing for
young programmers to get a handle on and
that's hard in a programming course.
Now we're going to ask a math teachers
to teach that and at the same time
sufficiently differentiated from the
equality concepts that they're learning in
the math book.
So this is a very tall order and it gets
worse because coding also doesn't have
numbers and you kind of need numbers to
do math. What do I mean by that? Well,
of course you guys know what one over
two is, right? What's one of your two
zero,
right?
Because in Java that's what you
get and you might say, oh, manual,
you're just being, you know,
you're just being silly.
A teacher needs to make sure that they're
teaching kids to declare things as a
float, not Annette. Maybe that's
true, except in a math class.
That's not part of the standards.
And so now we're asking math teachers
to teach kids about these different
partial representations of numbers,
which again,
takes valuable time away from actually
teaching math. And that's a problem.
But of course these
partial representations, no
matter which one you pick,
you're going to get
burned one way or another.
A math teacher will often teach
kids this important property.
If I have three numbers a, B, and c,
these two expressions are equivalent.
Y'All agree?
What if a plus B is too big,
right? Maybe a minus c buys us some
room before we have an overflow.
So the bottom one competes,
but the first one gives us
an error or maybe vice versa.
The bottom one is an underflow error.
So this statement that
these two expressions are
equivalent is now wrong in a
math class.
It's wrong
and it gets even worse because let's
say we use those floats, for example,
we'll float introduce error,
right?
Which means that these two
expressions are no longer equivalent.
Either we've just broken associativity
and distributively in a math class and
we're going to ask a math teacher
to teach it to. Even if we could.
These are known obstacles for transfer,
so if your goal is teaching Algebra,
this is deeply problematic. So what do
we do in bootstrap? Well, we decided,
you know what? Functional programming
is a pretty decent way to do this.
It enforces much more algebraic behavior.
We chose a language that has a
strong numeric tower implementation,
so numbers behave as close as it's
reasonably possible to the numbers that
behave in the book.
So we get a lot of the deep structural
similarities and then we actually do
programming using word problems
taken from a math book.
So we get some of that for free.
But what I want to get back to is this
idea that the takeaway should not be
functional programming is awesome,
right?
Functional programming is
necessary if your goal is Algebra,
but it is not sufficient.
You also need a curriculum that uses
functional programming because the
curriculum is critical if you want to
teach the process for performing those
tasks. So I'm going to explain this
using an extremely scientific graph.
So pay close attention. This is
very, very scientific. Um, uh,
we can graph a student's frustration
level as a function of the number of lines
of code that they've written. Um, and
typically it looks kind of like this.
So you give kids a programming
challenge and you say, all right,
kids solve it because they fire up the
editor and they're, they're starting here,
they're going,
I don't know where to begin.
That first line of code is sometimes
the hardest line for a kid to write.
Sometimes even for an adult.
This is essentially called
the blank page syndrome.
They're like,
w where do I begin?
But eventually maybe with some prodding
from the instructor or maybe on their
own, they start writing some code.
They're starting to get things going.
Their frustration level goes down
and students are kind of like three d
printers, right? They work
by additive manufacturing.
So every time they encounter above or
every time they encounter a new feature
with their solution, add more lines of
code, just more and more lines of code.
And gradually the complexity goes
up and they hit a bug. And the,
the way around the bug is,
I'll just check for that case and I'll
add more lines of code and so on and so
forth.
But eventually this path
becomes unsustainable and
it gets harder and harder to
fix those bugs. And eventually the
kid raises their hand and says,
my program doesn't work.
I'm stuck.
This is a common pattern in
computer science education.
And those of us in the room who may have
done some teaching of computer science,
may have seen some of this play out.
Now how do you deal with that?
Well,
let's look at any other discipline,
right?
Every discipline works in a completely
different way from this idea. They have,
uh,
like architects.
Architects don't start by pouring concrete
and then just adding stuff until you
get a building, right? They have three
d models. They have blueprints. Um,
let's say you're building a,
you're building a device and if you
are building the first mouse, right,
you don't start by ordering
a manufacturing prototype
and then adding to it
until it works, you probably think it
through with some circuit diagrams,
maybe some other kind of model.
Um,
the point is we don't just jump to the
solution and start hacking at it until it
works.
Typically what we do is we follow some
sort of multistage path to a solution,
right? We start with one
thing and then we build on it.
And that one thing is not the same
representation as the finished form.
An architect might start with a blueprint,
not concrete.
So we have these multiple representations
that we pass through on the way to a
solution and each representation
represents a different perspective on the
solution.
So one representation might be great for
answering one category of questions and
a different representation look
better for another category.
This multidimensional view is also
present in software engineering. Right?
Often there are specs, often
there are test cases. Often
there are long, you know,
uh, uh, user interaction
specs that are written up.
There are lots of things that go through
before you just instantly start coding.
And it turns out that there's a
multidimensional view that every teacher,
every math teacher cares about too,
which is functions,
functions have multiple representations.
I can think of it as a symbolic form.
I can think of it as a line on a graph.
I can think of it as a mapping
between domain, I'm sorry,
a table of inputs and outputs and
a mapping between domain and range.
So every Algebra teacher out there
already understands this idea of multiple
representations, multiple
stages, and multiple viewpoints.
So what does this look like
in a programming class?
So this is an actual worksheet from the
bootstrap curriculum that math teachers
use. Um, it's got a fairly simple word
problem. This one is aimed at programming.
So, uh, in the process
of making a video game,
so every bootstrap kid builds a game.
They need to write a function that
controls the movement of their target.
So we have our word problem,
write a function update target,
which takes in the targets x coordinate
and produces the next x coordinate,
which is 50 pixels to the right.
Step one contract and purpose statement.
We ask students to come up with a name,
the domain and the range of that function
and to write a purpose statement,
an English language summary
of what that function does,
and then we ask them
to write some examples,
update target given 10 the work it
should do is 10 plus 50 same thing for 20
then we ask students to identify the
pattern, what's changing, what's the rule,
and from there they can derive
sort of the finished form.
Now as software engineers, this
looks somewhat familiar to us, right?
That first stage kind of looks like
having them read a type specification and
maybe a comment as well.
That second part looks an awful lot like
writing test cases and then of course
the final representation is
then you go and write the code.
So students are doing all three.
A math teacher would totally disagree.
A math teacher would say, no,
no, no, no, no, no. That first
step, I know what that is.
It's domain and range.
It's thinking of a function.
A function machine is mapping between
these two sets. And that second one,
that's input output tables,
right? That's that little, uh,
the tea table mapping between discrete
input and output pairs. And finally,
I don't know what that code thing is,
but this is clearly the
symbolic form or the function.
So these representations
dovetail beautifully in the
context of a math class.
So we've got multiple
representations of code,
multiple representations of functions.
And with this as a scaffold,
we're able to manage this frustration
because at every stage students know
what's expected.
At first,
the very first thing I do is write
the contract and purpose statement.
And each one of these gives you a
different perspective on the problem,
a different viewpoint, which allows
you to build into the next stage.
So scaffolds are useful.
This is the explicit task that t that
student teachers teach students how to do
when they're programming the computer
that they can then transfer over to the
domain of math. When I'm working on a
word problem, I'll use the same strategy.
So when you look at things this way,
we sort of have the dependency graph if
we want to satisfy these constraints.
So there are three things that work here.
You've got to know what programming
language you're teaching.
If you want to teach computer science,
what language am I teaching?
You also need to have a curriculum.
How am I going to teach it, right?
What active activities are
kids going to go through?
And then you need a pedagogy.
What will it look like?
What is the explicit task
that students are learning?
And often we just pick one off the shelf
and say, we're teaching scratch. Great.
Now let's build a curriculum.
We're teaching python. Great.
Let's figure out a pedagogy.
But can you guess what the
dependency graph looks like here?
Wow.
Pedagogy first.
Anyone disagree?
If we're to draw arrows here,
where do they go?
I mean, it seems like you're
choosing language first.
You're going to choose scratch
if it right.
If someone says I'm going with scratched,
they would choose language first.
But let's say that you were starting
from a clean sheet of paper.
We want to change CS education.
We want to set up a class or an
after school club or whatever.
What does the dependency
graph look like here?
Is there a dominator or they codependent?
What do you think?
Maybe language last? Well, you can
approach it from any perspective,
but all three of them have
dependencies on each other.
The moment you make one
choice in this graph,
you instantly prune the tree
for what you can do elsewhere.
So here's what we did to build a
curriculum that could be integrated into a
mainstream Algebra class.
So I heard a volunteer say maybe we
should start with a language, so sure,
I'll start there. We knew it needed
to have easy unit tests, right?
It needed to be really trivially easy for
kids to create that input output table.
So that meant for us vertical line test,
we really wanted to functional language
so that we wouldn't have to manage state.
We also wanted the first class images
because images are engaging and fun.
And it's really nice if kids can just
write some code and see the output right
away as a computed output
from the function rather
than worrying about setting
up a buffer somewhere and then
retrieving it. But most importantly,
we wanted mathematical semantics.
We wanted to have that deep
structural similarity between tasks.
The main reason kids are
scared of math class,
they were scared of the
previous math class in the
previous manifest before that.
But what the kids think math
is his arithmetic. And as
soon as they see numbers,
their palms start sweating.
So when I've taught this kind of thing,
um,
uh,
we started with images on the first day
of class and we'd get to numbers about
week three or four.
Yeah.
So making images easily accessible,
lowering that barrier for some kids
can be a huge motivational boost.
So these were the criteria we wanted
that led us to choose the language we
wanted. And I just want to point
out, we started with the criteria,
not the language.
We started with those three things.
And from there we picked our language.
We didn't decide we were in love with
less than we wanted less per example,
but for our pedagogy we used
structured problem solving, right?
Because we want it to get that explicit
task and that problem solving strategy
had to be multi representational.
It had to use worked examples because
that's the pedagogy that math teachers are
familiar with and we actually borrowed
it from a phenomenal program that's been
running for more than 20 years at the
university level called program by design.
So it's an effective pedagogy
that's been proven successful.
We ported it to middle and high school
math and then finally you need a
curriculum and by the way,
for those of you that are interested
in teaching computer science,
maybe at a local school
or at a summer program,
a curriculum is not a list of
activities that is not a curriculum.
A curriculum involves lesson plans,
homework assignments, exit slips,
a warm up activities.
It's aligned to national and state
standards so that a teacher knows where
things fit. If you're expecting that
teacher to go and build this on their own,
looking at a list of activities,
it's not going to fly because guess what?
Teachers are really busy
and the curriculum developed has a
narrative final project that ties together
everything students have learned.
Every student in bootstrap builds a video
game of their own invention and so at
the end of the class, kids can do
a video game launch party, right?
It's sort of like a science fair for
the math department where they show off
what they built in their math class.
We believe that Algebra is the moment
where math becomes creative, right?
You're literally making
your own functions.
You're building your own
mathematical tools. Well,
let's make a video game out of it and
so you'll notice that what kids are
presenting here is not showing off
their cool graphics for their games.
Although they do show that we
actually have kids do code reviews,
parents, friends, teachers,
and sometimes visiting engineers
ask students questions,
why did you do it this way?
What would you have to change to
add this feature or that feature?
And students are required to look at
which representation makes the most sense.
To answer that question, is it
my unit tests? Is it my, my, uh,
type specification or am I
going straight to the code?
So this is something that we're doing
at the middle and high school level
because we're building on something
that math teachers already have them do.
Kids are used to going up to the
front of the room and explaining their
solutions.
So
that's what we do at bootstrap.
That's the strategy that
we've taken and you know,
we believe deeply in
equity scale and rigor,
and we can do this not just to Algebra,
but also through additional
curricular offerings.
So we've partnered with the American
Association of Physics Teachers to build a
bootstrap physics module that does the
same thing for a physics class that we've
already done for Algebra.
And we're also working on a data science
module that can be integrated into a
high school statistics class.
Or there are plenty of other classes
that use spreadsheets, right?
Business classes, civics classes, right.
There are students who might want an ask.
I think stop and Frisk is racist or
I think it's not. And guess what?
That database is publicly available.
And in the data science curriculum,
teachers can have students answer that
question themselves by viewing programs
as questions they ask of data.
And by aligning it to the standards
that teachers already have to teach,
we can embed this in a mainstream class.
Our vision is that a school should
be able to give kids at least three,
if not more, entryways into computing
throughout their high school career,
all without having to find room in
the budget for a new teacher or woman.
The schedule for a new course
if you want to get involved,
if there's tons of things that uh,
there's tons of places to help out.
We built compilers, we create
programming language, we live on the web.
All of our stack is built
on Google technologies.
So if you're interested in helping out,
but you're like,
I kind of want to focus
on the engineering side,
there's a ton of engineering help we
could use. If you want to be an advocate,
talk to your local school or district.
Ask them why their math teacher isn't
using computer science when they could
spread the word at the office
and of course if you'd like
to contribute, you can.
Our website is here.
I want to end on this note.
I think Google more than any other
company in the world right now understands
the importance of disciplined.
Sometimes engineering.
I mean you guys have thousands
of engineers working on
data integrity, right?
Just to make sure that one file doesn't
get corrupted when it's duplicated
across the network. Users don't often
see the magic that's going on there,
but Google understands that that kind
of stuff is critical for building a
scalable infrastructure.
So often in the tech sector,
when we approach education,
we stop thinking about it
as an engineering problem.
We'll just dive into what we were taught,
what we think is cool,
what we think kids will enjoy.
We lose the engineering side of things.
This baffles us at bootstrap.
We've never understood why.
And here to tell you that computer
science education is one of the most
sophisticated engineering
problems in existence.
It's waiting for someone to
step in and do some of the deep,
possibly unsexy engineer and work
to create a solution at bootstrap.
We've built one of the largest and most
diverse cs education programs in the
nation and we did it at a fraction of
the cost and with a team of four human
beings.
And we did it because we look at the
problem like engineers working at startups
scale and imagine what a
company like Google could do.
So I want to leave it there. I'm happy
to answer any questions you have.
This is an engineering problem that
is built for a company like Google.
Absolutely, yes. So the question
was do we test the kids?
And I'm so glad you asked. That is
literally my secret. Last slide. Whoops,
load.
This should be mirroring. Can you
guys see my screen here? Okay, great.
So the answer is yes.
You better believe we test the kids and
in fact the tests that we use for our
initial study all involve questions drawn
from national and state standardized
tests. Not because we're in
love with standardized tasks,
but because we understand that decision
makers want to see that kind of stuff.
And what we've seen is the testicle,
he significant evidence of very large
gains on three tasks that we've looked at
so far. Function, composition,
solving word problems and matching
between representations of functions.
Okay, so this is, this is pre and post
the kids who got this great collaboration.
The kids, you got a standard
Algebra credit lower table.
Is that the upper table is pretty imposed,
is that correct?
No, the lower table is a demographic
distribution. So this table,
so this table right here
is showing gains pre, post,
not looking at a control group.
I will say that this is the
first curriculum ever to
have demonstrated evidence
of transfer.
We're gathering additional data.
We're building a much larger data
set that includes control groups.
So we'll be able to
compare apples and oranges.
But historically this belief that learning
to code will help you in math class
has not been true.
The simple fact that this table exists
was something we're extremely proud of.
We've been able to make that happen.
Great question.
Yeah.
Staff for years afterwards
when they go to college,
when they actually get it for a job.
Unfortunately, maintaining data
on minors is extremely complex.
I mean, I'm with you. I, I wish I could
stand here and say we've tracked these,
these thousands of kids and we know
what happens to them. We don't, um,
what I can say is the schools that have
adopted, bootstrap continue to use it. Um,
and I mean it's, it's not hard data.
It's proxy and anecdotes at this point,
so I can't answer that.
Yeah. Yeah. Can you talk a
little bit about your choice of,
here's a lot of conversation about
what the AP who doing muses. Dictation.
I graduated from high school
pretty recently and a lot
I talk about shifting the
bathroom. Teaching pocket. You program
with your job did use your pipeline.
If you teach it through an autogrow class,
it makes sense that you use some things.
I'm with less list or something
to make it useful to Algebra.
But is it still useful outside of
that class in an engineering context?
So I heard sort of two questions in there.
So one of them you were saying it's
sort of how did we choose our language,
right? What, what factors go
into it? And the second is,
is functional programming
useful outside of a math class?
No sugar itself,
but the way that you teach it,
does it make sense to students that
would be useful outside of the context of
that?
Absolutely. Right. In fact,
the program by design curriculum that I
mentioned is used in universities around
the world.
They actually use the same language that
we're using and we borrowed the same
design recipe.
So a student in,
in Boston can go over to northeastern
university and they will see, oh my God,
the freshmen cs majors are doing the
same work that we do. Um, and in fact,
I don't know if you want to, if you
want to mention this because there's,
this is a parallel in New York as well.
Well,
I'm no longer enter Delphi.
So how long are you using this approach
in their, in their CF zero class.
But it was for, for a number of
years while I was being here.
That's a Delphi University.
So that mid level, uh,
liberal arts school where I was on the
CS faculty and we had a CF zero class
programming for poets
programming for non majors.
And we did it this way and we had a fair
number of students who had such a good
time that they became cs managers.
Um,
and they seem to learn, uh, learned a lot.
So,
so there are parallels directly into a
number of universities around the world.
But more, more importantly than that, yes.
Functional programming isn't a
whole bunch of companies as well.
It's used in plenty of
industrial contacts. So the
language itself transfers.
But yeah, especially big data. That's
right. But more significantly this,
this approach that we're using,
the structure, problem solving,
writing a type specification.
And you know,
thinking through your unit tests
deeply before you dive into the code,
that's a high level skill that's relevant
no matter what language you're using,
right? I mean, I, I went to the bathroom
before giving this talk and you know,
I think Google is famous for your testing
on the toilet pages. Um, you know,
this is something that that is
transferable across languages, right?
This is where you get to explicit a
process that transfers everywhere.
Um, as far as how do we choose our
language or like why, you know,
I think this debate about should we
use python or should we use Java?
It needs to be about what
is our learning goal?
Computer Science teachers are the only
teachers I can think of of any discipline
that when you ask them, what do
you teach there answer is the tool.
Imagine if I asked a math teacher, what
do you teach? They might say Algebra,
geometry, Calculus, right? They're
not going to say calculator.
If I ask a chemistry teacher, what
do you teach? Maybe Orgo, right?
Maybe some physical chemistry.
You,
you'd think they were crazy if they
answered and said, I teach bunsen burner.
But when you ask your average cs teacher,
what do you teach?
There answer is Python Scratch Java.
It's the only discipline where they self
identify but the tool and that's the
problem.
We cannot folk overfocus on the tool
because there's this dependency graph that
requires that we think a little
more broadly. Other questions?
Yeah.
Initially you had said you were
an afterschool program then
maybe the changes were that we were
really large and then you shop.
I want to
expand on what happened and why.
Yeah, sure. So we uh,
we actually partnered with a
terrific afterschool program
called citizen schools.
They are national in scope.
They're very active in New York and I
know Google has done some work with them
in the past on third great
shooters back then. In fact,
I was a citizen schools
employee at one point.
Here's what we noticed when we were
doing an afterschool programming club.
So first we needed volunteers,
so we had to recruit tons of engineers,
which is not easy. Second engineers are
busy people and sometimes life happens,
right? You have a ship
deadline, the build is broken.
So one engineer has to piece out and
can't make it that day. So what do you do?
You have redundancy.
You recruit three,
four or five engineers to make
sure that at least one or two,
one of them can be there every single day.
So we have to recruit five engineers
just to teach this afterschool program,
which is typically how many kids?
Maybe 20 maybe 30 if that.
I've got it. It's like, yeah. So,
so we're spending all of our time
recruiting engineers who need a lot of
training to teach, right? You
guys are experts at the content,
but teaching is hard too.
So we're investing a ton and trending
engineer's five engineers to eight kids,
and now those engineers,
once you've trained to them,
they come back every semester of forever.
Right? They just keep teaching. No, what?
Yeah. Right. So then they get
busy. They leave the project.
So you have to recruit enormous numbers
of volunteers who you lose almost
instantly just to reach 20 kids.
If you're lucky,
a single public school math teacher is
going to reach 80 to 100 kids in a single
year. And if they like what they're
doing, if they believe in the program,
they'll do it forever until they die or
retire, whichever one comes first. Right?
So if you're thinking
about scale as a priority,
afterschool is amazingly flexible.
There's a lot to recommend it,
but scale is not one of them.
Yeah.
Was one
you're showing like the math word in here.
Like what about
separate metric?
So I mean, essentially we use
summit of assessment, I'm sorry,
formative assessment
throughout the curriculum.
So once we spend about two lessons
teaching this explicit task,
this multi representational task,
the moment that's over every single
thing in the curriculum is a word problem
where kids are given a problem to a
problem statement or problem to solve and
got. And so we're able to assess
as they go through the program,
are they able to complete it? Where are
they stuck? Um, to be really upfront,
the level of programming we teach in our
Algebra module is fairly small, right?
We're not doing object oriented
programming. We're not doing, you know,
recursion for example.
Um,
but we have an extraordinarily high
percentage of students who finished the
program,
build a video game on their own and we
use that as a proxy for their learning to
program.
There are some learning studies that were
in the process of doing the reason we
haven't,
we didn't start with those are because
for us we felt that showing math outcomes
was the most immediate concern.
Um,
but we're gathering data and we're looking
to report on the CS learning outcomes.
I was a teacher
before.
If you've touched it shows
it's something that I should,
I'm just curious like what do you think
are the biggest factors that we just
schools adopting or not adopting?
Bootstrapper
my school's willingness to train factors.
So, right. I mean, right now our,
our capacity problem is we do not have
enough staff to train teachers fast
enough. There are far more teachers
who are looking for training,
then we can train in a
year. Um, but as far as the
bottleneck at the school, right.
What makes a school
successful? Um, I mean,
I think a significant part of that is the
administration needs to believe in the
program because if a math
teacher comes to our training,
gets excited and then it goes back to the
classroom and start saying, all right,
we're going to do this. And the
principal looks in the door and says,
why are kids making video games?
Right? Why are they even on a computer?
That principle,
you know,
justifiably might be hesitant about
somebody messing with their math scores.
And so often we hear from
teachers who are saying,
I really want to teach the program.
I wasn't able to get the
administrative buy in.
So there's a messaging issue for us.
There is something of a bottleneck around,
look,
some schools do not have even enough
computers for a once a week laptop card
that's starting to disappear,
right?
Were the hardware problem is
starting to get solved. Um,
but I think the,
the,
the third most common issue
is a sense of teacher support.
So this is an area in particular where
Google can be enormously instrumental,
right?
It's,
there's tons of teachers using bootstrap
in New York City public schools right
now.
I would say a percentage of them are
thinking to themselves, all right,
I'm doing it.
It sure would be cool if I could have
an engineer just come and visit my class
like once or twice just to like have
my back and to talk to my kids. Right.
That boost,
that sense of there could be someone I
could call upon that would be tremendous.
Even if that teacher never calls on you,
just knowing that they could can be the
difference between them teaching it or
not teaching it. Um, so I think that's,
those are the top three bottlenecks
I think people, I hope people would, yeah.
Google search month.
There you go. Oh, is it perfect? Yes sir.
I did teach for America and I
taught one or hostile years. Um,
so just like try to put myself in the
shoes and I do like kind of touched on it.
Just stand,
don't like teacher buy in
is very intriguing because
I can see at least like the
teachers in my school,
ones that had been there for 30 years,
every year there's some new way to
teach math and they're like, listen,
I've got to town by now
and it kind of discarded.
But like on a bigger scale and your
district kind of federal where,
where are we on?
Because eventually you feel like we
get to the point where it is curriculum
wouldn't be required or like it's so
ingrained in our society that we need to
have it on kind of a bigger level.
Like where are we?
We're, we're not even at the
starting line. Um, so, so
in terms of teacher buy in,
that's something that we excel at.
I'm on a former math teacher.
So in our trainings we, our
math teacher, the math teacher,
we focused heavily on the math.
Typically we don't mention the con,
the computer science learning
outcomes because we're,
we're there talk math and the veteran
teachers buy in at a deeper level than the
young bucks because the young teachers
are like, finally computers. Cool.
They're not necessarily thinking
about the math connection.
The veteran teachers see it.
So we've,
we've been fairly successful there and
it took 10 years for us to get to that
point. So it's not an easy thing to do.
Um, but as far as the federal level goes,
it's a hard engineering problem.
Right?
Scale comes not from getting to 10
million kids in your first year.
It comes from building
up a pool of teachers.
Maybe you only train a
thousand teachers a year,
but every teacher you train keeps
doing it until they die or retire.
Right now the trend in scale is how
do get to 10 million kids in year one.
And if that's the threshold, guess what?
Youtube videos we'll do youtube videos,
the teach program math through programming
like that. It's quick, it's easy,
it's cheap,
you don't get the rigor and you don't
get teacher buy in for that either. Um,
I think,
I think a lot of governors have made
some really terrific proclamations about
getting everyone to code and then it
falls to the superintendents and their
states to figure out how to make that
happen. And what winds up happening is,
well, we used to have this
class on PowerPoint and excel.
That's kind of like a program in class.
Let's have that count to see us.
So sometimes we're repurposing an
existing class and calling it cs or we're
doing hour of code one hour a year,
kid does it.
We taught computer science check.
Um, and we'll take the, you know,
the elective route,
which has its benefits,
but it also has some drawbacks I think
in order for there to actually be a
policy movement on this,
it's someone needs to tackle
the engineering problem
and get buy in and say this
is, we're going to build
something scalable but it's
not going to happen in one
year.
And unfortunately that that sales pitches
is hard to make when someone else says
I can do it in a year and I can do it
for cheap. All I need is a video crew.
Yeah.
So what you just said about,
uh,
the issues that you have,
proper citizen school.
I pretty much agree with that
about the issues about how
cars, a lot of it, a lot
of expensive resources
takes a long time to build
off all of this stuff. Um,
so what would be,
would you have advice for people that are
interested in doing this type of stuff
and actually would like to dedicate
some time over the long term?
Like how do we approach this
type of problem? Like what
for people that aren't going to go
in like start or join your bootstrap
well,
what are your constraints?
Are you thinking like career
change or are you thinking
you like what would be the type of thing
that you can do for a couple hours a
week and so useful and meaningful impact?
So I think, I think this, you know,
that kind of thing is where you
can be complimentary to an Oregon,
to an afterschool organization
like citizen schools, like
afterschool, all stars,
right?
Maybe you personally decide,
I'm going to invest in
teaching an afterschool
program in class through one of
these programs,
but I'm going to be responsible for
recruiting and maintaining a rotating
community of volunteers,
right, of coworkers.
And I'm going to make sure that they get
trained and since maybe you've done it
two or three times,
maybe you can be the one to train them.
If you keep that pathway sustainable,
you can start to have a bigger impact.
Um,
option to connect with an
organization like bootstrap and say,
I want to be available for
any teacher who has questions.
I would love to just be able to work
with those teachers even though I've only
got a couple of hours a week. Um, I think,
you know,
there are summer camps that they don't
necessarily hit the equity angle all that
well, but you can do so much when you
have kids for eight hours a day for three,
four, five weeks. I mean,
you can do a lot there without having
to give up an entire, you know,
part time year.
That's interesting.
Thank you.
Yeah. All right. Well, I know
our time is up and everyone,
everyone's really curious to hear
about the testimony that came out.
So I'll leave you guys to it.
But, uh, thank you so much
for having me. Thank you,
Google, for all of the technology
that we have built our platform on,
so we really appreciate it and
thanks especially to my host, Andrew,
for setting this up.